means memes memes
all right we're about to react to
Medical I guess they're not MediCal dog
memes and I brought my good friend bear
bear You're gonna laugh at these right
yeah you're gonna laugh at them memes
high five oh you almost punch me other
high five yeah memes high five
where do you see yourself in 20 years me
turning into a dog honestly I think
owners look like they're dogs I don't
know how that is true because we're not
related to our dogs but maybe our
selections are based off that so do you
think I look like this do I look like
you
[Music]
look for the girl with the broken smile
broken smile
[Laughter]
[Music]
when the doctor takes an x-ray of my
heart oh it's a little wiener dog I love
weeder dogs they're so cute they have so
much personality they do Yap a little
bit too much they do kind of ignore your
commands but otherwise they're really
sweet they love to snuggle and honestly
medically I would say you have cardio my
weiner apathy
[Music]
wiener megaly cardiomegaly means you
have a large heart weiner megaly means
you have a larger friend it's a short
trip pack only what you need me and the
dog bear you always want to go in the
suitcase but you can't fit I searched
for my dog for 20 minutes oh my god
that's literally bear bear this is you
bear looks like a bear rug on the floor
most times do you remember when bear was
little he used to lay on my lap like
this and I could just pet him like that
now his head's bigger than his whole
actual body borkers Yorkers boofers
yippers you first woofers I understand
what a yipper is they're kind of like
yippee dogs a euphora kind of get two
they go borkers bear you would be in in
the mix of a boofer and a borker I would
ask him to bark but I'm like 99 sure he
won't do it there if I had treats you'd
listen to me
you have one hour to eat 500 nuggets who
do you choose to help you honestly I
think if I put out 500 nuggets bear eats
all of them in a minute 47 seconds I
wish we could test it in a healthy way
but we probably can't without hurting
bear what's your ideal work environment
yes honestly bear sitting but not on my
lap he's too heavy for that he'll break
the chair we just weighed him in at 1 30
the other day him sitting at my feet
keeping my feet warm that's the way to
go lost dog doesn't bark much well
behaved likes Metallica this reminds me
of friends when they used to have the
pet duck oh look it's oh I forgot the
name of this dog it's a whippet closed
captioning not available
or some kind of no I think it's a
whippet see I know my dog breeds
[Music]
my owner has been gone for 0.02 seconds
9-1-1 have you tried eating the cake
okay bear doesn't eat the couch because
he's a good boy the secret to not have
to having your dog not eat the couch is
crate training them early on that way
when they're in the crate they're not
going to be eating the couch when they
come out of the crate you could
visualize what they're doing and make
corrections as needed and only allow
them out of the crate under direct
observation to make those Corrections
right bear that's why you don't need the
couch give me a kiss
no kiss
oh thank you yeah you don't need the
couch before you eat my face
dare I say Chihuahua muffin come on
honestly blueberry muffins are one of my
favorite foods and I grew up eating them
and I kind of hate that I did because I
think that's what secretly destroyed my
cholesterol you have no idea
created fat in fat there is in muffins
I think it's just like oh it's like a
little snack no it's not a snack it's a
hidden treasure Trove of saturated fat
and calories and carbs Jurassic Park oh
my God bear has a Halloween costume of a
dinosaur we'll put it on shortly don't
stop
retrieving hold on to that feeling
feline
pronounced feline there do you like cats
I'm gonna do this this is gonna get me
in trouble if this video gets 300 000
likes I will consider getting bear a pet
cat that looks just like him a brown cat
do they make brown cats
corgia South corgilina North corgilina
you know what's funny the other dog that
was considering getting bear as a friend
was a corgi because I feel like I've
grown out of the phase of wanting a very
athletic dog I want a chill dog Bear's a
very chill dog but imagine having two
chill dogs you'd have them smile at each
other like this all the time like jeez
let me in so I can tell you I want to go
back outside again yeah that's most dogs
that's why I'm happy bear doesn't have a
doggie door so I can just keep him
inside all the time right you you know
bear reminds me of those troll dolls
look at that
how do you feel about his mohawk look at
that I'm not fat I'm just a little husky
oh and it has two different color eyes
those are so cute you gotta try and keep
your dog not obese because dogs that
carry extra weight live shorter lives
they have problems with their hips so
that's why we're trying to keep bear
nice and trim I don't mean his hair
because that's clearly not trim but his
body is very nice you could just barely
feel his ribs so you know he's in a good
good body habitus CPR not working let's
hide the body that's funny bear does
that all the time especially if I'm
lying down does your dog bite no it's
worse she touches when um bear comes up
to people and people like oh my God can
I pet your dog I say yeah sure just be
careful and as soon as I say be careful
they panic but what I'm saying is be
careful he slobbers half the people say
oh my God I don't want to get my clothes
dirty but he's so cute and then the
other people welcome his drool on their
face as if it's moisturizer and I'm like
all right you're going too far I grab my
keys my dog honestly if I come up to the
door and I put on my shoes bear does not
react but if I come on and he hears the
jingle of his leash that's a game
changer finally a political movement I
can get behind Thor Michaelson says no
to vacuums they're loud and they freak
him out honestly bear doesn't get scared
of vacuums but if you come next to him
with the vacuum and like your vacuum
next to me he freaks out he wants to get
away Pixar bear look it's a cone well
actually when bear uh had his surgeries
I didn't get him a cone I got him like
this round inflatable pillow thing he
seemed to be more comfortable with it I
almost had a heart attack this morning
oh it kind of does look like a tiger oh
that's funny how is that dog so tall I
don't even know what's happening here to
be honest I feel like this is Photoshop
oh this is the Drake meme doesn't like
the fireworks loves the tennis ball
honestly bear will fetch maximum five
times and then I don't know if he's
tired or he's over it but he doesn't
like fetching more than five times she
called you a good dog a thousand times I
just remember one time six years ago
when she told me I was a very very bad
dog honestly I disagree I think dogs
don't remember anything Negative they
only see the best in you
I did the math we can't afford the cat
oh bear we already promised them 300 000
likes bear where are you going just
trying to get comfy all right so do you
want the cat or not waiting on my
luggage it's a
signs me of the stick from the short
that we put up where it was like 295
dollars the world's most expensive stick
would still pet
explosive dog how would we write that we
we wouldn't write explosive dog we would
say bomb sniffing dog I bet you're an
explosive dog would you have explosive
diarrhea a Bus full of former Bad Boys
headed home from Good Boy camp oh
with seed plot this is the most safe
School Bus of dogs I've ever seen so
your owner made you fetch the ball but
they never actually threw it I'd say you
have a strong case for fraud bear go
again go bring It come on
yeah that's a good boy look he brought
the Roxy head that he's destroyed lay
down it's Dog Wars yeah let him
entertain himself while I'm oh he's over
it that was is quick what my dog is
called Charlie what I call my dog
pufflebophus mock ponzo foffel Pritchard
Ernesto bushy boy Bears nicknames bear
floof noof doof doggo I think that's it
this dog comes with two subs
oh that's really cute I have the same
backpack for bear but I use it to hold
water bottles when we go hiking to give
them a little extra weight someone
should invent an alarm clock where the
alarm clock is the sound of a dog about
to throw up because nothing wakes me up
and gets me out of bed faster than that
honestly so true it's actually happened
when we film videos weaknesses worried
about their social status inflexible
all right
[Music]
the bear just throw up and the only
reason I get up so quickly is because
this dog for some reason will throw up
and just lay right back down into it
like he's going for a swim when I see my
co-worker's dog in the background of the
video chat I am that way and every time
bear pops up into my videos everyone's
talking about it too my emotional
support dog after one day with me
honestly I feel like bear would run out
of empathy really quick if uh he
actually knew what I was talking about
when I unload my feelings to him
actually that's why he's tired right now
because last night I was going through
it and I couldn't sleep so I had some
anxiety so I started telling him all my
problems so I think he's he's carrying
that burden right now it's not breaking
HIPAA if you tell your dog about your
patience right
by the age of 30 you should have a dog
anxiety and a dog
[Music]
to God at age 33 I cannot see a more
accurate meme I have a dog I have
anxiety and I have a dog with anxiety
actually I don't know he doesn't look
like he has much anxiety how it feels
sharing the bed with my dog oh my God
that is me if I let him on my bed not
only is it incredibly hairy but there's
no room because he's giant do dogs
understand elevators or are they like
okay it's time to get out into the world
change every time the elevator door
opens bear gets in it but I don't think
he understands what's happening I think
he just sees a door open and he thinks
that's the next step because that's been
his progression for so long but you know
what is interesting if the elevator
stops at a different floor he knows not
to get off so what's that about what
does he know about that floor that I
don't know me hungover AF trying to find
the ibuprofen aisle be careful with
Ibuprofen when you're hungover your
stomach's irritated from alcohol you
have a little gastritis ibuprofen can
make it worse how my dog sees himself
when the doorbell rings honestly bear
acts so hard when the doorbell rings and
then the second someone comes in he just
starts licking them and like welcoming
them and showing them where all the
valuables are it's like the exact
opposite of this he is purebred
I would like for my next dog to be a
rescue my biggest concern is where to
find one that matches my personality and
how that whole process works so if
anyone has tips hit me down below I'm
sorry Jack there's not enough room
there's all these dogs James camera just
came out with a statement and said that
it's scientifically not plausible for
both of them to have survived and
actually the book that I'm reading was
interesting in that they talked about
whether or not our emotions would change
if she invited him and he said no if he
asked to come on and she said no and how
would that affect our viewpoints of
these characters I thought it was a
really interesting discussion what would
you think if he got on there with her
with another person and one of them had
to jump off or get pushed off and she
pushed off the other person what would
your thoughts be about her did you know
that bear was actually attacked in a dog
park by a golden retriever click here
for that full story as well as some tips
on what to do in case you witness a dog
fight as always stay happy and healthy
oh and get your merch you know you got
to get those organs it's actually right
down below as well